Schroepfer: Hi, folks.
Hey, up here.
You guys over here,
if you want to see the panel,
you can move down this way.
Otherwise, enjoy your laptops
on that side.
Welcome to the Browser
Perspective panels.
I'm Mike Schroepfer.
I am your moderator
for today.
We've got three
great panelists here
representing a variety
of viewpoints
on where browsers are going.
We've got Charles,
who's been working on standards
for about ten years.
For the last four years
he's been working
with Opera software.
Part of the W3C.
Part of many of the emerging
web standards.
Let's welcome Charles
to the panel.
Yay.
[applause]
Boo?
Charles: [laughter]
Schroepfer:
Save that for later.
Next to Charles
we have Jonas.
Jonas has also been working
for for browser technologies
for about ten years,
first as a Mozilla
community member,
and now as a--
the last several years
as a full-time
Mozilla developer.
Been concentrating
in the DOM,
and also a participant
in many W3C working groups.
Welcome, Jonas.
[applause]
And Ian is a product manager
on Google Chrome.
He's been with the team
since 2007.
He works on core infrastructure,
security,
and focuses a lot of his time
on HTML 5
and emerging web standards,
and has been
an active participant, again,
in the web standards
working group.
So welcome to our panel, Ian.
[applause]
All right,
so I'd like to kick it off
with a couple of questions,
and then we'll definitely
open it up to the audience
to see what things
you are curious about.
Start with you, Charles.
I'm curious as to
what you think
the most promising emerging
standard is on the market,
and why you're excited
by it.
Charles: Uh,
that's a tough question.
I think one of the things
that I'm really excited by--
Doug wants me to say SVG,
which is what I was gonna say.
But I think that's
pretty much emerged,
and, you know,
it's out of the closet.
The access to device
information--
the location, the camera,
the SMS,
the address book stuff.
And the reason I'm really,
really excited about it is
because it makes us
get security right.
So like, if you start
telling the web
where people are
and who they talk to
and what their device does,
you've gotta
get security right
in a way that we've
never really done before.
And doing that means
we can really go out
and make cool things
and let 'em run.
So I think that's probably
one of the most exciting things
happening right now.
Schroepfer: So, Jonas,
if you could make
every other browser vendor
implement one standard today,
what standard would that be?
Jonas: Uh, I would probably say
one of the things
I would really like to see
is OGG support
for the video tag.
Having free video
on the web is--
[applause]
It's very, very important.
And it's also a standard where
we don't yet have--
Everyone is behind
the video tag,
and that's very good.
Making it easier for people
to put video on the web
without relying on things
like Vimeo or YouTube
is really good.
But also having it--
allowing people to do it
for free is very important.
With standards like H.264,
for example,
there's a big risk that everyone
that puts video on the web
is gonna have to pay money.
And at Mozilla,
we have really worked for
making it easy and cheap
to put stuff on the web.
So...
Schroepfer: Okay.
So, Ian, bringing this to you,
if you could uninvent
a standard
that's in existence today,
which standard would you
uninvent?
Ian: So I think if I could
uninvent a standard,
what I would uninvent is
things that are sort of
de facto standards,
but not actual standards.
There's a lot of these things
out there
that cause problems for us
sort of alternative browsers,
if you will.
One great example of this
is ActiveX.
You know, it's not
an actual standard
that we all sat down
and agreed upon.
But yet, a lot of people,
especially in the Asian
regions--
Like, if you're looking at
e-banking in Korea,
Japan, China,
they're all using
ActiveX controls,
which isn't something that
we can support on Mac and Linux.
It's not something that,
you know,
we all sat down
and tried to figure out
what's the best API for this--
how do we do it the best way?
So I think a lot of these things
that are sort of
proprietary standards
that never really made it
through the web standards
process--
I would love to see us have
an opportunity to go back
and figure out, you know,
what are we actually trying
to support here?
How can we do this
in an open way
that everyone can implement?
Implement securely,
implement Cross-Platform.
And just do it in a more
webby, standards-friendly way.
Schroepfer: Okay, I've got
an open question for the panel.
So whichever of you
would like to respond.
If I'm a web developer--
so I'm building websites,
for example--
and I wanted to talk
to the browser vendors
and lobby on behalf
of a particular new standard,
or change a new implementation
to be done,
how do I get in touch with you?
How do I help influence
the process
by which you decide
what you're gonna build
in the next version
of the browser
that affects the entire
web ecosystem?
Charles: So the dumb answer
is email, right?
Because we all read
a lot of it.
I think part
of the smart answer is
you get your users to become
very visible.
If you've got something
that you're building,
then show that it's interesting.
Because the browsers look around
at what's going on in the web.
A lot of the input
to things that we're gonna do
in standardization
comes from things that people
are trying to do,
and getting frustrated by.
So building it,
and then, instead of hoping
they will come--
because eventually we will.
But building it and then
going to talk to us and say,
"This is what I want,"
you know...
And doing it somewhere, like,
you know,
go and talk to the W3C--
the working group--
or submit it
to a relevant group
where a bunch of browser makers
and a bunch
of the other parts
of the ecosystem
are already present.
Because it's not just browsers.
You've got to have browsers.
You've got to have the tools
that people are gonna use.
If you build something--
If we build some format,
and you can't make
authoring tools for it,
then we've got a problem,
right?
Because you've got a bit
of the ecosystem missing.
But basically make it,
and then find the forum
we're sitting in
where we talk about this stuff.
3D Canvas is an example
of something where--
We went to a place--
we ended up at Cronos,
which seemed to be
a reasonable organization.
We would like it to be more open
in the way it works.
But it's got the right people
working on the right technology.
And, you know, Mozilla,
Opera...
People out in the wide world
all went and said,
"We want to do 3-D stuff.
Let's go and do it together."
Jonas: I think showing that
there's a need for something
is a very good way
of building support for,
or ensuring that browsers
will get excited
to implement something.
There's an infinite number
of suggestions,
and it's very rare that
someone sends in a suggestion
to a standards body
or to a browser--
just shoots away one email,
and then everyone gets
so excited about that idea
that people start
implementing it.
It has happened, and it's
usually very small things.
But more what happens is that
you do the best you can
without it, or--
So for example, with 3D,
as soon as Canvas came out,
people started doing, like,
Doom and 3D games in Canvas.
And it's horribly slow,
but it sort of works.
You can sort of see
potential there.
So people did the best they can
with the tools that were there,
and thereby showed that
if we only had
this other tool as well,
we could do the things we're
doing, but more awesome.
So that is a very good way
of getting browsers
and getting standards
organization to take interest
is to show that there's
an actual need for it.
Ian: I know a lot of people--
if I could just answer quickly.
I know a lot of people out here
look at us up here
and see, like, Google,
a giant company.
Mozilla, a big browser.
Opera, big player.
Been around
for quite a long time.
I think probably one
of the oldest browsers?
Charles: Yeah, I think we're now
the oldest browser
delivering active development
and still around.
Ian: So people look at us
and think, like, "Oh, my gosh,
"they must have a ton
of resources
and giant teams
to work on all of these."
But the reality is that we do
sort of have to pick and choose.
You know, we're looking at,
you know--
what are people actually trying
to do,
as Jonas and Charles said?
The other side is that,
you know, for Chrome, at least,
and Mozilla as well,
we're open-source.
If you really want to see
something implemented,
patches welcome.
Go to dev.chromium.org.
All of our source code's there.
We're all hanging out on IRC
and pound Chromium on Freenote.
And you can come talk to us
and pitch an idea and say, like,
"Look, this is this
really cool thing I want to do.
"And by the way,
I implemented it.
Here you go.
check it out."
That's a great way
to get it in there too.
Charles: It turns out that
there's no shortage of things
that we could be working on.
It's about what other ones
that are really important
to the world.
So you know,
just implementing code,
it's like, you know,
is one part of a step
that you can do.
But showing that
this is something that is,
you know, gonna be important
to the world,
that this matters
to other people,
is a pretty critical step to
get something to be a standard
and not, you know,
a private project.
Schroepfer: So turning
the question around,
what, as browser developers,
do you wish
more web developers were doing
to take advantage of
next-generation technologies
in existing
or upcoming browsers?
What do you wish you saw
on the web?
Jonas: It's really awesome when
you put the new technology--
even if you just--
especially when you put it
in an alpha or beta release.
And to see people start
playing around with it
and do amazing things that
you had just never imagined
that people would do with it.
Like with the Canvas,
when that came.
So playing with early
alphas and betas is
a really good way.
And also, these people tend
to find bugs,
and these are bugs that
we can fix before the release.
And this prevents things where,
you know,
there was a bug
in an initial release,
and now everyone has to deal
with that bug,
and we can't fix it because
people have started
depending on it.
Fixing those things before,
because people find them
in alphas and betas,
is really nice.
Um, also, like,
just pushing the limits.
Daring to do demos,
at least,
that only work
with one browser.
I can understand the reluctance,
and I do want people
to develop sites
that work in all browsers.
But at least playing around
with technologies
that only exist in one browser.
Not necessarily Firefox, but
you're welcome to do that too.
But people playing around
with new technologies
and doing things
that we had never imagined
is really cool.
Charles: Sorry, go, Ian.
Ian: I think we talk a lot about
this chicken and egg scenario.
You know, I don't know
if you're the chicken
or if you're the egg.
But a lot of us want
to think that, oh,
the other person needs
to do something first.
And I think that, really,
we just need to act.
So on the Google Chrome team,
we're starting to look
at CSS3 and Vertical Text.
Is anyone really using
Vertical Text right now?
No, not really,
but on the other hand,
there's no option to do it.
So we're just gonna go ahead,
and we're gonna do it.
And I would love it if
some of you
content publishers out there
would go ahead
and start implementing
Vertical Text on your site,
even though
it might not work yet.
Because when it does,
there's gonna be a lot of users,
like Japan, you know,
surprised.
They wake up in the morning,
and their newspaper is
still vertical.
It hasn't changed--
their language hasn't changed
just because the web has
some restriction.
So we're working on lifting
those restrictions.
I would say that
what would really help me is
if you guys would start working
on the parts
that you have control over,
such that when we're both there,
it'll just work.
And I think that the first time
that someone wakes up,
and they see, you know,
oh, my gosh,
Wikipedia is now Vertical
in Japanese.
It's like reading it
in a newspaper.
Oh, my gosh, this web comic
now has Vertical Text,
just like the manga I read
on my table.
You know, I think
that's going to be
a very, sort of,
eye-opening moment.
And after that happens,
it'll accelerate demand,
and people will start creating
more content.
More browsers will start
implementing.
And so I would say just forget
the whole chicken and egg
argument, and just do it.
Charles: So I'd also like to
say, you know,
figure out the experimental
stuff and, yeah,
get all of the
experimental toys,
and play with them
and push them,
and make experiments
and show us where, you know,
this thing can go.
And show us where
we should be thinking next,
and give out all the new ideas.
And figure out how to separate
the experimental stuff
and the hacking around
from building ordinary stuff.
Ordinary stuff should be
built right.
So you know,
if you're building a piece
of crazy,
experimental sculpture
to show off what can be done
with a material,
you build a crazy thing.
If you're building a bridge,
get the standards right.
You know, figure out
how to do it properly,
and use the technology
that we've got properly.
And that's really important,
because the more time we spend
messing around
existing broken rubbish,
the less time we spend
doing interesting things.
And that frustrates
our engineers,
who like making cool stuff
rather than patching bad HTML.
And it frustrates
the developers
because the browsers spend
all their time patching bad HTML
instead of giving
more interesting functionality.
Schroepfer: So one of
the challenges of pushing
new standards and browsers
is getting those new browsers
adopted on users' desktops.
I'm sure, as anyone
in the audience
who's building
a major web site,
probably still has to support
both IE 6 and Firefox 2,
because together they're
a reasonable portion
of their user base.
What are all of you doing
to aggressively get your users
to upgrade
to the latest version
of the browsers
that have the latest
and newest standards?
Ian: I can answer that.
[laughter]
If you're running
Google Chrome,
you're running
the latest version.
Which I know Firefox does
some auto-updates,
not quite as aggressively
as Chrome.
But I think that,
you know,
there's certainly a good case
to be made
for doing automatic updates,
and I'd like to see more people
move towards that direction.
It helps keep the web browsers
up to date.
And that's good not only
from a functionality
and standards perspective,
but also, when there's
a security bug that we patch,
we're able to push out
an update,
and it goes out to the vast
majority of our users
very quickly.
So I'd really like to see,
you know, more browsers--
Charles: Have a look at
our containers.
Go to Auto Update in it.
[chuckles]
Yeah, there are some issues
with Auto Update, right?
There are issues about systems.
People who run, you know,
very secured systems,
or systems where,
for some reason,
they want to have a lot
of control.
You don't put
the space shuttle onto
the beta version of anything,
right?
And there are other places
where you don't want to
update everything automatically.
If you use a browser
twice a week,
and you pay a lot of money
for your data,
you don't want the browser
costing you ten bucks a week,
'cause that's five bucks
a page.
You should be able
to turn the update off.
You should be in control.
But yeah, Auto Update,
making it easy for the user
to just have the thing
that is the latest version
is important.
Making the latest version
actually better quality--
You know, make sure that
it's an improvement
and that it's a real upgrade
and not a, you know,
"We made a new version, and
you should have that anyway."
Because if you do that
a couple of times,
people say,
"Well, wait a minute,
"you guys don't necessarily
improve--
I don't want to upgrade."
So that attention to quality,
getting stuff right
is important.
Jonas: I think it's--
There's definitely advantages
and disadvantages
to pushing the latest version
automatically.
It is scary to push
a new major release
because there's always gonna be
some amount of things
that break
with a new major release.
If you fix a bug,
a site is gonna break.
That's just how the web works.
So pushing new major releases,
we're talking a lot
about how to do that.
I think it's very important--
For security updates,
it's very important
that it's--it's--
because they come so often,
it's important that
it's very smooth,
and it's unnoticeable
for the user
so the user doesn't
get bothered.
Because nothing really
should break over that anyway.
With major releases,
I think it's very important
that users know
that there's an upgrade.
We find many times that
our users
that are still on Firefox 2
just didn't know
that Firefox 3
had been released.
Somehow they missed
the dialogue.
Even if we'd pushed up
an announcement
two or three times
to all the users,
somehow they missed it
because maybe their mom was
using the computer,
or someone else was using
the computer
and just clicked "cancel"
because they didn't know
that they wanted to upgrade.
So it's very important
that users know
that there's an upgrade.
And it should also be very easy
to do the upgrade.
The easy part is something
that we decided
very early on in Firefox--
it should be almost transparent.
The user should just,
at the most,
have to click a "yes" button.
If users have to download
and install
and go through
an entire process again,
you immediately drop
a big hunk of users.
If you can't do it
in two, three seconds,
you've lost a bunch
of users already.
So whether to push,
automatically, major releases,
we're still debating.
There's definitely users
that want both ways.
And I also think
it's very important
that users are in control.
If users don't want to upgrade,
they should be able to,
at all times,
make a conscious decision
and say,
"I don't want more upgrades."
For whatever reason
there may be.
Charles: So there's
another issue, right?
My father-in-law is
82 years old,
and his computer is not quite
as old as he is.
But it runs Windows '98.
'Cause it turns out
that I couldn't find
a Linux distribution
easily available
that would fit
on the machine.
And it also turns out
that I could only find
one browser
that's a modern browser
that will fit into the machine.
There's a lot
of this stuff around.
So, you know, wanting everybody
to have the latest everything--
It's like, you know,
one solution is
go out and buy
the whole world
the latest piece of hardware
to run it.
But that's probably not
the best way
we could spend all our money.
So you've got to
actually recognize
that some of these limits
come from things
that are quite important
to people,
and things that are
pretty fundamental.
Schroepfer: So looking at
the composition of this panel,
I'm noticing two
major absences.
Our friends at Apple
and Microsoft are not here,
which collectively have
more than about 50%
of the browser market share, if
I have the recent stats right.
What are you doing
to work well
with the entire
browser community
to make sure that, as a new
and important standard gets out,
it gets implemented
across all the major browsers
so that web developers can count
on that feature being there
when they're deploying
their web site
in the real world?
Jonas: I find a very
important part is
in the standards process--
when you're defining
a new standard--
it's very important to get--
to have all the parties
that have interest
in the standard
and are going to implement
the standard,
to have them involved
so that they can give input.
First of all, I think if you
don't have a party involved,
it's very easy to accidentally
put something in the standard
that someone just can't
implement--
that is just physically
too hard.
Some of those things are
actually already on the web,
unfortunately.
But...so there's
that aspect.
The other thing is that
it's just--
if someone just
throws a standard in your lap
and says,
"Here, go implement it,"
then you'll be
much less excited to do that
than if you get to be part of
the development process.
You get to give your input.
You get to put your print
on it.
So that way you'll be
more excited about it
than going forward
and implementing it.
So I think getting
all browser vendors involved
in the standards community
is very important.
Schroepfer: So are you working
with Microsoft and Apple
directly on these standards
today?
Is that a process as well?
Charles: Yeah, yeah.
It's nice to know that Apple
is involved in standards stuff
much more than they're in
anywhere else.
It's a pain in the ass when it
turns out that they're involved
because they sent their
patent declaration
and said, you know, "We're gonna
block all of this stuff."
And we've got to figure out
a way around dealing with that.
But in general, yeah.
These other browsers are
actually involved
in standards development.
I think another important thing
that we do is compete, right?
Each browser has users.
Each browser has developers
who are pushing
what they want to do,
and following the latest
Fileo
and the interactivity stuff
in Opera,
or the latest stuff in Firefox
or Chrome or whatever.
And because we're actually
competing with each other
as well, we're looking around
and seeing, you know,
what is it that attracts
these people
to some other browser?
And part of it is
the new functionalities
that they develop.
The fact that Firefox
and IE and Opera
and Apple and Chrome
and other browsers
that no one here knows of
all have active communities,
and support them,
and get them developing stuff,
keeps all of us on our toes.
Makes us look around and say,
"We've got to follow that
as well."
We've got to actually
figure out
is that something
that's worth standardizing--
that's worth doing
across the web--
or is this some weird thing
that's gonna die off
in a corner?
And when a browser
comes up with something
and makes it work,
it's great, you know,
if you take it and say,
look, we want to standardize
this.
It helps the browser,
It helps the developer
community,
and it helps the other browsers
have a reason
to sit down and talk
to each other.
Ian: I think we should point out
that everyone up here--
You know, first of all,
we're nice people.
But we do try to be as open
and as--
We do as much outreach
as we can.
So when we're developing
something like Canvas 3D or O3D,
we tend not to see it
as some whizbang advantage
that's going to get more usage
for our browser,
and get people to switch
from other browsers
because only we are gonna
support O3D, Canvas 3D.
That's not what we're trying
to do.
Like, what we're trying to do
is figure out
how do we move the web forward?
And so when we do things
like Canvas 3D, you know,
there was a very active effort.
Everyone from Mozilla was
reaching out trying to see,
okay, how do we get people
from Google?
How do we get people
from Opera and Microsoft?
And how do we get all the people
to the same table
and talk about this
so that when we're actually
developing this,
we know about the issues
ahead of time?
We don't want to get
to a point where we have a spec,
and two years later,
the other browsers,
who weren't the first to
implement, start implementing
and realize, oh, my gosh,
this doesn't work
in a multiprocess model,
or, oh, my gosh,
we can't do this
on top of Direct X
because the OpenGL Shader
Language is different.
You know, we do try to reach out
as early as we can
because we want to know if
there are these sorts of issues
that are gonna hold us up.
Sometimes it's unfortunate
when we find out these issues,
be they patent issues
or technical issues,
because, you know,
sometimes they're setbacks,
and we want
to get things done quickly.
But I think that we all realize
that it's much better for us
to find this out early
in the process,
as opposed to at the end
of the process.
So I think we're all trying
to be as open as we can.
Jonas: The whole, like,
implementing a standard
in order to compete
kind of doesn't work.
I've never heard of any user
switching to Firefox
because we support
animated PNG, for example.
People switch to browsers
because websites work nicely,
because the browser works nicely
with the user.
Generally speaking,
most sites write such that
they work in all browsers.
So--that's generally speaking.
But there's very few times
that I'll switch--
or someone switches to a browser
because it has a new standard.
If a standard only works
in one browser,
no site is gonna rely on it
anyway, generally speaking.
So there's no competitive
advantage there, really,
for users.
Charles: Well, so there's not
for users,
but there's an advantage
for developers, right?
Jonas: Yes.
Charles: The developers want
to figure out
how to play
with the new technology.
And in order for developers
to experiment
with new the technology,
they do go from one set
of new technology to another,
figure out what they like.
And it's not that, you know,
implementing this feature
is gonna get my mom
to switch her browser.
But it will give a developer
a place to experiment.
So there's standardization,
and there's innovation,
and they're separate processes.
Innovation is where you start
building the experiment.
Standardization is where
you've seen the experiment
and what people have done
with it, and you've said, yeah,
we need to actually
make this work properly.
And then we take a step back,
and we get it all right,
and we make sure it works
on mobiles and in Arabic
and in Japanese
with Vertical Text,
and in dual-processor systems.
And so the innovation stuff
that drives the creativity
and the development
comes back down
to standardization
at a different level.
So I agree that, you know,
you don't win users
because you implement
some standard thing.
But you do get creativity,
you get innovation,
and you get a chance for people
to make applications.
Schroepfer: So if you're not--
I'm sorry.
If you're not competing
on a standard
on the web platform,
what's the pitch
from each of you
in terms of why I,
as a newbie user,
should use Opera,
Firefox, or Chrome?
And why are you competing
in the market?
Why not join efforts into one
super-browser project
where you pool your efforts
into building
the latest and greatest
web-rendering engine?
Charles: Because we'd have to
downsize all the engineers.
Jonas: We don't like each other
that much.
Ian: I was just gonna say,
I mean, it's not that we don't--
We do sort of compete.
Like, things like JavaScript,
you know.
There was a slide
in the keynote that showed
how fast JavaScript
had gotten.
If there weren't
multiple browsers,
I don't know that that curve
would be as sharp as it is.
You know,
within the past year,
we've seen JavaScript
in all the major browsers
make leaps and bounds.
And I think that, you know,
part of this is
us competing
for developer love.
Part of it is just, you know,
if you're a user,
and you're loading Gmail,
which is getting more complex
as more features get
added in,
you want that to load quickly.
And if you start realizing that,
you know what,
it's taking ten seconds
in my browser to load,
but when I switch
to Google Chrome,
it comes up in one second...
You know, maybe then
that's gonna force the--
convince the user
to switch over.
So you know,
we're not trying to compete
in terms of these are standards
I'm going to implement,
these are standards
I'm not going to implement.
But we are certainly competing
in terms of user experience,
how well do we render the web,
how shiny is our browser,
how nice does it look,
how does it feel
to use this overall?
Charles: A lot of the pitch is,
you know,
the browser makes your life
better, right?
The more the browser
helps you do--
the things you're actually
trying to do.
Because very, very few people
in the world
have a job of using
a browser.
It's like mostly their job is
use the browser to do something.
And making that thing
work better for them
is a big bunch
of where we compete.
Why do we not all do,
you know, the same thing?
Yeah, I agree with him.
We would stagnate.
We had the fastest JavaScript
engine around for ages,
and we didn't do a lot
of work on it
because nobody else cared
about speeding JavaScript.
And so nothing happened.
And then all of a sudden
people said wait a minute.
They started building
these heavy Ajax apps,
and JavaScript became important,
and we pushed each other.
You know, engineers are
individuals,
and groups are slightly
different,
with different cultures.
They're interested
in slightly different stuff.
They compete.
People like competing.
So a race to build the fastest
JavaScript engine
is much more fun when
there's more than one entrant.
Because a one-person race is
kind of dull to watch.
And not much fun
to participate in.
Jonas: Yeah, I mean,
the performance is definitely
an important aspect
of how we compete.
There's also, like,
user experience, stability.
It's basically,
the interface towards users are
a major competitive point.
Do I like the Chrome UI and the
features that Chrome provides,
or do I like the Firefox UI
or the Opera UI?
So it's sort of how
you interact with the browser,
which browser
you feel comfortable with
that's more of a competitive
vector.
Also, performance has gotten
very, very important lately.
I think there's just been
some sort of critical mass
behind the performance message.
Also, websites have gotten
so complex
the they actually get
to be slower.
And so that's why people care
about performance these days
much more than we did
just a few years ago.
Schroepfer: So speaking
of JavaScript engines,
between the, you know, 2x,
3x year over year improvements
in JavaScript speed,
and new standards like
worker threads,
which allows me to do
background processing
without locking up
the main UI,
there's a lot more power
on the client
than there used to be.
Like, by some benchmarks,
the JS engines are faster
than many other
interpretive languages,
like PHP or Python.
If I'm a web developer,
and I'm re-architecting my site
or building a new site
from scratch,
and I'm making a key decision,
which is how much work
do I do on the client
versus the server?
Or which work do I do
on the client or the server?
What's your advice to me
on how to figure that out?
Charles: Carefully.
[chuckles]
Ian: Make it modular.
The nice thing about
a good modular design is that
it should be pretty easy
to take some module,
some part of that
and shift it over.
So I'd say that, you know,
if your--
if you want to be
really forward-looking
and think, you know, okay,
how do I take advantage
of what's coming up in browsers
the next few years?
How do I take advantage
of speed?
of new features?
Design your code in such a way
that, you know,
if there is a part that
you think might be separable,
write it in such a way,
such that, you know,
two years from now,
if it might make more sense
to do it on the client,
it's easy to swap it out.
Don't write it as just
one giant monolithic PHP file
that, you know, is one class,
one function.
That's gonna hurt.
And that's just good
coding practice in general.
Jonas: And there's
a general coding rule
that's something, like,
"too early optimizations is
the root of all evil."
And that's, like, if you start
thinking about performance,
and start doing performance
before you actually have
anything else,
and then you are probably
gonna optimize things
that you don't need
to optimize.
And it's much better
to optimize for code quality
so that once you have
something working,
and you can see what is slow,
at that point
you can optimize that.
There's also the case that
the platform--
The web platform changes
extremely rapidly right now,
so whatever is
the correct answer now
is not going to be
the correct answer in two years.
So you better be prepared.
You better build your code such
that you can easily change it.
Charles: You also want
to think about--
You know, the web platform
is not like a single platform.
The difference between
a small device--
you know, a Nintendo DS,
which is a pretty
low-spec machine
compared to some
shiny new laptop--
You don't necessarily want
the code to run the same way
on both things.
So keep it simple,
you know.
One thing, just cut it down,
if you can.
And figure out, you know--
As Ian says, work out where
you can shift stuff across
from one to the other.
Keep your code flexible so
you can deal with the changes.
Ian: I think that a lot
of the advice that we've heard
over the years--
especially when CSS started
coming out,
people were, like, you know,
you need to be really good
about separating
your program logic
from your presentation layer
from your data.
Had you done that, you'd be in
a much better state right now.
Because when mobile started
taking off,
you could say, well,
I've got my application code.
That's still pretty much
the same.
My data isn't really changing
that much.
But my presentation layer sort
of needs to change from mobile.
So that transition might not
have been
quite as painful for you.
Now that we're talking
about offline,
you know, if all of your stuff
is service side--
all your presentation logic
is service side,
and now you're trying
to move that offline,
that's gonna be hard.
But had you separated that
a few years ago,
you could say, well, okay,
now some part of that is
moving down to the client.
But I've already got
this nice separation,
so there's a layer
I can rewrite.
So I think a lot
of the advice
that people have been giving
for years still applies.
Charles: And I go back
to the "carefully" thing,
because it's like--
It's not enough to say, well,
I have all this stuff in CSS
and HTML and JavaScript.
I've got all this separation.
It's how you actually conceive
of the stuff,
how it fits together.
Because you can write
one huge piece of code
that is actually very cleanly
and beautifully structured
in your understanding
of how it works.
And you can simply
pull pieces out and put 'em in.
And you can write stuff
that's got modules
all over the place
where, in fact,
the modules are just this
giant spaghetti stuff
connecting things.
Schroepfer: So this is great
general advice.
Can you think of
specific examples
you could point people at
where you think people are
taking advantage of the next
generation JavaScript engines,
or offline, or worker threads
to do things in a way
that we maybe wouldn't have
built web applications before?
It's a good example for me,
as a web developer,
to see here's an example
of how you could use
some of these next-gen
technologies.
Jonas: I thought it was pretty
cool the other day when I--
Because I use--
To read email on my phone
I use Safari and Gmail,
'cause I use the iPhone.
And it was pretty cool when,
a few months ago,
or a few weeks ago,
all of a sudden the UI changed
and became much snappier.
And it turned out
that it was because
they're using the client-side
SQL API.
And so if--
I don't know exactly
how the caching works,
but many times, instead of
having to download
all your emails,
it has them already
on the phone.
So it was noticeably
more snappier.
They're still working
on some bugs,
because oftentimes
you end up seeing
two old emails, and you have to
manually refresh it.
So there's definitely
still bugs there,
but it's a very interesting
sort of first draft,
or first take
on improving performance
by using these new APIs.
Ian: And I think that
the current trend towards
using web toolkits,
be that GWT
or other toolkits out there--
You know,
as it becomes possible
to do more things
on the client,
or do things in different ways--
For instance, if some code
that you compiled on GWT
would now run better
were you using a worker thread,
that change can be made
in the toolkit
so that you,
as an application developer,
might not even have
to do anything.
We, as the toolkit provider,
could make that change.
So I think that, you know,
if you're able to use a toolkit,
not only does that help you do
some extraction and clean code,
but it also helps other people
help you.
So not to sort of be
all Google here,
but things like GWT
are certainly a good way to go.
Schroepfer: So last question
from me,
and then I'd love to
open it up to the audience.
So we have a microphone
on this side
and a microphone on this side.
If you want to ask
our panel questions,
please come on up
to one of the microphones,
and we'll get you part
of the discussion.
So my last question:
many of you mentioned mobile.
Let's be honest, the browser
state on mobile is a total mess.
I'm sure you've seen
lots of blog posts
from people looking at
state of implementation
of different standards across
different devices and phones.
As a web developer,
it's really hard to understand
exactly how to understand
this landscape,
and how to support--
you know, if I want to support
a billion people
on all of these
different phones,
it's a gargantuan effort
to do it.
So what are all of you doing
to help us clean up
the mobile mess,
and get a better set
of supported,
standardized browsers
across mobile devices?
Charles: Make better
mobile browsers.
Jonas: Yeah.
Charles: I mean,
it's not rocket science.
It's just, you know,
hard work.
Jonas: I think the big problem
on mobile--
I've not done any
mobile development myself,
but from what I've heard,
the big problem is that
there's just so many--
there's so many players there.
It has been so easy to build,
like, a crappy browser
and put it on mobile phones,
and then people try to use it.
Whereas...instead of building
a full-fledged web browser.
That's what we at Mozilla is
definitely pushing
as an answer to, like,
how do you do a mobile web?
Let's just put the normal web
on the mobile web.
Let's put full web browsers
that have
all capabilities of
desktop browsers on cell phones.
Like, doing something
cut down is--
that's a very short-sighted
solution.
People want to use
all manners of web pages
that aren't mobilized yet.
And in order to do that,
you need a full web browser.
And also, web developers
want to use all the features
that they've become accustomed
to use on desktop.
So they also want
a full browser.
Ian: I think people are also
voting with their feet.
People meaning both end-users,
but also phone manufacturers.
So right now we see
a huge sale of iPhones.
I see a lot of people
in the room with Androids.
I'm not sure why that is.
I think they gave some out.
But you know,
if you look at these browsers,
they all have--
I'm sorry,
if you look at these phones,
they all have pretty
full-featured web browsers.
Both iPhone and Android browser
happen to be based
off of Webkit,
which is sort of cool for me
because a lot of the work that
we do on the Google Chrome team,
we just check straight into
Webkit.
Which means that, you know,
not only does it end up
in Safari on the desktop,
but also ends up
in the Safari browser
on iPhone.
It ends up
in the Android browser.
So I think Webkit is actually
doing a lot of great things
for mobile browsers.
Certainly the Opera guys have
a ton of experience
on making good mobile browsers.
And people are voting
with their feet
when they go and download
Opera Mini for their phone.
So I think that, you know,
voting with your feet
is also a great way
to sort of encourage people
to do better
in the browser space.
You know, if you're looking at
buying a new phone,
buy one that comes with
a good browser.
Charles: Yeah.
Ian: Or buy a good browser.
Charles: Or just get
a good browser.
Download Opera Mini,
you know.
If you've got an old,
crappy phone,
one of the issues is phone
systems have been pretty closed.
Phone operators have been
reluctant to allow people
to just install
whatever they want
and do whatever they want
with their phone.
And they've been pretty tight
about what could go there.
And phones last a long time.
The people who go out
and buy a new phone every year
are a fairly small shim
on top of the market.
And the phones, you know,
are out there.
If you go around the markets
around the world,
you find ten-year-old phones
all over the place.
Millions and millions
and millions are sold every week
of ten-year-old phones.
So part of the issue is, here,
we have this legacy.
And working out how to build
systems for old devices...
How to bring not the sort of
20 or 50 million
richest people in the world
to go out and buy
the fanciest new thing,
but the billion or two
who haven't got
the fanciest new thing,
and also haven't got
a desktop computer,
and are gonna use the web
on their phone,
and will use whatever works
on their phone--
We've gotta deal with that,
because that's a huge part
of what makes up
the market.
Schroepfer: You want to
step up to the mike?
You got a question
for the panel?
man: Sure. I'm Vinny,
from PGP Corporation.
You guys know us
from encrypting mail
and data content
and stuff like that.
I have an interesting
observation.
I've noticed this over the last,
I don't know,
seven years, eight years.
As more and more of the content
has been
moving up onto the clouds,
into the web,
the fear that I have
is that
that content isn't
very well protected.
Now, when I say "protected"
to a browser developer,
they tend to say to me,
"Well, sure we are.
"We do SSL, TLS,
or whatever,
and we protect the data
going up and down."
But what I'm thinking about,
and what I hear often
from, you know, the CSOs--
the chief security officers,
the technology officers...
folks like the FBI;
people who care about
the data itself--
is that the data itself
is not protected.
Let me give you two cases
in point,
and I'll offer you
a possible solution.
Most companies that have very,
very savvy chief security
officers
will not let them use iPhones
to access their mail sys--
They won't let them use Gmail.
Because there's no way
to encrypt that data.
I can't send an email
through Gmail
and encrypt it, and worry
about it being decrypted.
Yeah, the pipe is protected,
but that's data's
out of their reach.
Another good example is--
and I've seen this happen
a lot now.
I've seen companies move
their data offline.
Gosh, we used some third party
to do performance reviews
for employees.
And it was interesting to see
that they were typing
all this stuff on what the
employee was gonna do next year
into this off-site web site.
I said, well, gee,
did you vet the employees
of that off-site web site?
How do you know that that data
is not well-protected?
And you know, so again,
I've seen this trend of things
moving up there
onto the web,
and people doing backups
off-site.
Now, we've done a couple
of hacks over the years.
I've tried to address this.
Done some NPAPI plug-ins.
Maybe thought about using Embed
to specify the data
that is embedded is encrypted,
and that only the clients
can look at those things.
But you know, if you look
at the Android phones, and--
Schroepfer: Sorry,
do you have a question?
man: Yeah, I do.
I'm saying that if you look
at the Android phones
and the iPhones and stuff,
those browsers don't
really offer you
any way to extend them
to identify that data
should be secure.
What I'd like to see happen
with the browsers,
and maybe with HTML
and whatever,
is for you to start
thinking about how to encrypt--
how to specify that data
be encrypted.
Again, my fear is that,
you know,
People, like, wonder
about things like Facebook.
They say, "Gee,
I put these photos up there,
"but then Facebook can
look at it,
or somebody else can
look at it."
I'd like to be able to encrypt
that data as a customer,
and only let my friends who have
the right keys look at that.
That's my opening question.
Ian: I think one of the problems
with encryption
that we've seen so far--
You know, there was this great
sort of seminal paper
a few years ago called
"Why Johnny Can't Encrypt,"
which was a great usability--
I think it was called
"Why Johnny Can't Encrypt."
man:
It's pretty old, yeah.
Ian: A great usability study
on PGP 5, I think.
man: We're at ten.
Ian: Yes, you're at ten.
But one of the things
that came up is it's very hard
to actually figure out
how to teach users what to do.
You know, people--
Encryption is not something
that people naturally think of.
You know, I'll buy
the argument
that people might want to
protect their email.
That's a very logical thing
to do.
They might want to protect
what they put on Facebook.
But I think that
one of the first things
that really needs to be
worked out
before we go down the path
of standardizing PGP
into the browser
is figuring out
how do we actually
make this usable?
You know, show me that
users are actually--
That there is a good UI
for doing this,
that users want this,
that there is large demand.
I'm pretty that you could
do this in JavaScript
with a Chrome extension
if you wanted to.
You know, that might be
a radical statement,
but JavaScript performance
has gotten really good.
It's a Turing-complete language,
so given enough time,
you probably should be able
to do it.
If someone showed me
a very compelling UI
that would let someone in Gmail
or on Facebook easily say
encrypt this content,
and only let my friends see it,
and they worked out all
the user-experience issues
and said, "Ian, you know,
I've solved it--here it is,"
that would be very compelling
for me.
Right now I think those
UX issues are still unresolved.
I don't mean to demean
any particular product
for implementation,
but I think we have
a long way to go
before my mother can
figure out
how to send
an encrypted email to me.
man: So let me retort to you
that along--
A lot of stuff has happened
since that paper was written.
And that I'd say about 90%
of the corporate Fortune 100s
is using, in fact,
our product.
Okay, um, yes,
I agree with you.
I'd like to see something
like Embed--
encrypted text,
something key, whatever;
leave that up to
the implementers--
It should be a control panel
no one ever sees.
But those questions are
being solved.
Charles: So the questions are
being asked.
You know, at the beginning, when
I said the exciting technology
was, you know, all this access
to sensitive information--
And it's exciting because
it's not a technology question.
The security stuff is not about:
can we encrypt stuff?
We know how to do that.
It really is about
how do we get people
to understand
what they're doing?
And how do we get them
to think about it?
And it's really,
really complicated.
And every time
you get it wrong--
You know, if you train
a micro-generation of users
to do something that turns out
to be a bad idea,
then you've taken
this huge step backwards.
We have all this
certificate stuff where,
you know,
all of the browsers say,
well, you know,
we've got this certificate,
and it's unsigned, and it's,
you know, low security,
and it doesn't really work.
Do you want to continue
putting your credit card number?
What do we all do?
Ian: Yes.
Charles: Yes.
And we are the experts,
right?
And we take this huge
backwards step.
We have learned to do
the stupid thing.
So we've got to figure out
as we get this right--
We've got to figure out
how to do it
in a way that teaches users
and in a way that users
understand what they're doing.
How to do the right thing.
So the research is not
technology.
The research and the development
is behavior.
And the web is, you know,
a very, very big environment.
Researching behavior
and people's understanding
on the web,
that's complicated stuff.
And we're doing it.
man: My question's regarding--
with the increase in touch
and multi-touch
as a user interface,
not only for mobile devices,
but also laptops and computers,
that has an implication for how
you might use the web browser,
the features of the web browser,
and how you might design for it.
I mean, even with the iPhone,
it has multi-touch features,
but it also stops it from doing
some other types of interface.
I'd like to hear your comments
on what would you regard as
sort of the best practice
for dealing with
this sort of new touch
and multi-touch environment
with user interface?
Jonas: We've had recent
discussions with a vendor.
I'm not sure if I can
tell you who.
But about coming out with
DOM API's new standards
for doing multi-touch,
and so on.
One of the early problems
we discovered
as we started doing
mobile stuff--
this is a long time ago,
not the current effort--
was that you went to Gmaps--
to Google Maps--
and you wanted to scroll
on the map,
instead of scrolling the map,
what you ended up was
scrolling the page.
And so there is a effort--
the DOM advanced effort--
to try to standardize
this better.
Because, like you say,
there's overlap
in the various ways
you interact with the browser.
And so it's not
a solved problem yet.
There are various solutions,
and they are being debated.
I haven't heard, like,
where that standard is--
what the latest news
on that standard is.
But there's definitely
efforts there
to sort of improve
the situation.
Charles: The guy who's
supposed to be working on it
is sitting over there hiding
instead.
Jonas: So it's a very
hard problem to solve.
Especially that fact that
today there are so many things
that want to react to, like,
on click.
Whereas, if you're, like,
dragging on a touch interface,
that is sort of a click,
but sort of not.
And how does the page or browser
know which one you want to do?
So I suspect that there is
slowly gonna come new standards
to deal with this.
And then, once the standards
have been slowly deployed,
websites will slowly start
to take advantage of them.
The best help here is
gonna be
when more people start
mobile browsing.
So the more this turns into
an actual problem for people
and for websites,
the faster we'll find
a solution.
Charles: Right, there's this
legacy of dirty, messy code
that is causing problems.
And everything we try and do
gets complicated
by the fact that there's a whole
chunk of the web out there
that will break if we do
anything that seems intelligent.
And so, you know, if you guys
go back and figure out
how to clean up your stuff,
then that would be helpful.
That would be a part
of the best practice
that will enable us to build--
us all--
because developers do
most of the thinking here--
to build new best practices
and make things go.
But interfaces change
all the time.
Controlled interfaces--
touch and multi-touch
and gravity stuff.
And you go into
the accessibility world,
where you have people
with disabilities
who've been using
brain-wave control, literally,
and voice and multi-touch stuff
for years and decades.
There's a lot
of this stuff around.
It's about figuring out
how to integrate it.
And it's really about, you know,
how can we clean up the way
that people understand
the interaction piece
of an application
so that we can make nicer code
and nicer APIs available
without busting half the web?
man: How do you see the future
and the role
of browser extensions?
Jonas: I think browser exten--
I mean, to me,
the browser is really is your--
Once you have installed
a browser,
it's your piece of software.
You should be able to do
whatever you want with it.
And so the more powerful
extensions
that are available
for that browser, the better.
So I'm definitely very
pro browser and pro extensions.
I mean, look at the extension
community we have for Firefox.
It's really amazing.
And I'm sure a good chunk
of the reason
people switch to Firefox
is because
there's some extension
that they want.
The downside, or the other side
of that is security.
We want people to be secure
at the same time.
And the more sort of power
we give to extensions--
the more things they can do,
the more awesome they get--
the bigger the risk that
they do something evil and bad.
Or the risk that they have
some security problem in them,
and someone hacks them,
and then you have full access
to whatever power
that they had.
So I definitely think
that extensions are
a very good thing.
And we just need to sort of--
It's not a perfect system yet,
and it's never gonna be
a perfect system.
But we need to improve, and
we need to make it more secure
and easier to deal with.
The other side too is the
Greasemonkey-type extensions,
where you actually extend
web pages.
And that's one of the things,
I think,
where HTML has really triumphed,
in the sense that you could
never do something
like Greasemonkey
for your desktop applications.
The applications I install
on my iPhone
are never gonna have, like,
Greasemonkey plug-ins
that allow me to, like,
improve the applications.
But the websites I use are--
The ecosystem around the web
is such that you can
reach into various aspects.
You can change the looks
of things.
And you can also add
functionality,
or change functionality
as you want.
So that is a very
powerful thing of the web.
And I think that's, uh...
I don't know if it'll be
a major competitive advantage
to the web, as opposed
to desktop applications,
but it's definitely
something that,
for the people that use it,
it's a very powerful thing.
Ian: At the beginning
of the talk,
we were talking about
how do you use a browser
to decide what to implement?
And I think it was Charles
who said, you know,
if you go out there and you show
that there's a need for it,
and a lot of people want it--
that will implement it--
I think extensions provide a way
to show that need.
A few years ago, when phishing
was just sort of entering
the common vocabulary,
Google went out and put on
an extension for Firefox--
the Safe Browsing extension,
which basically provided
warnings
when you hit
a suspected phishing site.
And now that functionality is
in all the browsers.
Why? Because we showed
that we could do it.
People started downloading it
and showed that there was
a demand for it.
And it was validated
as a reasonable idea.
And so now it's one
of the standard things
on most browsers.
So I think extensions have
a great role
in not only just customizing
your browser
to meet your experience,
but also in validating that
something is a good idea
for a browser, and that
there is demand for it,
and that it should become part
of the standard
browsing experience.
Charles: So extensibility
gives a community a chance
to either show
where a browser should go,
or take something--
You know, a lot of the stuff
that we've done at Opera,
that's like Mouse Gestures
and things we've had for ages--
speed dials and stuff--
people go and develop
as Firefox extensions.
It gives you this quick way
of copying stuff,
or of testing stuff out.
It suffers from some drawbacks.
You don't want
your core functionality
to be based on, you know,
some chain of extensibility
because the inherent difference
in security and stuff.
So you want to use that
as a way seeing
where people are going,
what's good
as a guide to, you know,
what should you bring in
to the central core?
But extensibility in general--
that's a programming paradigm.
Helps people do stuff.
man: Specifically, what
functional or design patents
have inhibited, I guess, the
development and implementation
of new browser standards?
Charles: You mean by number,
or just, like,
the author and date?
[chuckles]
man: In general, I guess.
What have you run into
where maybe Apple or Microsoft
has said nope,
you can't do that,
or do it differently?
Ian: I think some of your
question is alluding to, like,
our people saying,
"No, don't do that."
But I think a lot of it is
just practical constraints,
at least on the Chrome side.
We look at things like
Web Workers.
And it seems like
that should be so trivial
to implement in Chrome.
But then we hit
all these issues like, you know,
to do XHR from a Worker,
you need to know the origin
of the request.
A simple thing.
But when you're
in multiprocess land,
like you are in Chrome,
you are in a separate process.
You might not actually
have access to that data.
So on the Chrome side,
we actually hit
a lot of these practical
considerations that--
You know, before we released,
people developing
these standards
weren't necessarily thinking,
you know,
how is this actually gonna
play out
in a multiprocess environment?
And now people are actually
starting to think about that.
And so that's--
I don't know if that's
functional or--
That's one of the things
that is certainly interesting
from my perspective in terms
of things that sound like
they should be easy,
but actually turn out
to be quite hard.
Charles: Was your question
about patterns or patents?
man: "Patents."
Charles: Oh, patents.
man: Yes,
like registered patents.
Jonas: Well, the first thing
I think when you say patents
is video.
The video situation right now
is really, really bad
in the sense that
there's all sort
of ridiculous patents
out there.
And the most popular format,
and arguably
a very good format, is H264.
We just can't use because
there's patents on it.
There's just no way.
And we would love to do it.
There's code out there.
There's open-source code
out there.
We could just, you know,
plug it in.
But we can't, technically
and financially, do it
because of patents.
And similarly...
everything around video is
so heavily patented
that Apple has said that, well,
OGG looks decent enough.
But if we implement it,
we have no idea
if we're gonna get sued
because it's very likely
that there's a patent somewhere
that no one has thought about,
or that might be
a submarine patent
that no one knows about yet.
And so they just, out of fear
of getting sued,
they don't want to implement it.
No one knows to a patent,
but just, it's--
There's probably a patent,
or quite possibly a patent.
man: Do you see a solution
for these kind of problems?
Charles: So walking into any
new area of technology--
Every time the web goes into
some new area of technology,
you find that
in most areas of technology
there are patents.
And some companies,
you know--
I don't know of Microsoft
holding a patent
over anybody to stop development
of the web at any time ever.
And I do know of them,
before the W3C patent policy--
which was a fairly radical step
of saying, you know,
"We want people to make
a royalty-free web.
We want the stuff to be
patent-free, if we can."
Microsoft voluntarily stepped up
and said
we've got this patent,
and we will put it down
on the conditions which are
what are now
the W3C conditions.
In things like Voice, you know,
going into Voice.
In, as Jonas said,
video is a minefield.
Going into a couple of areas,
there have been patents.
Apple is currently excluding
a patent on the widget space.
And, you know, the solution is
that we sit down
and we look--
either with the patent holder--
You know, because
people file patents,
and it costs them money,
and they do have a right to say
I want to actually recoup
some of the money
I got from this work.
But you can either sit down
with the patent holder
and say, well, all right,
if we're going to do this,
either we agree
to all pay up money--
And in the W3C world,
that's not an answer.
It's like, we've gotta
figure out a way around it.
So Apple can come and help us
work out
how to avoid infringing
their patent,
and still provide
a functionality
that's the thing
we were aiming at.
Or we go out to the community
and say, look, you know,
we're not getting anywhere.
We've gotta figure this out
as a community,
and it's a big,
complicated process.
It's like, what is the history
behind this patent?
What other patents are out there
that might cover something--
An expired patent that covers
similar stuff that we could use.
Or some prior art
that shows the patent holder
that actually it's not really
worth their while
enforcing this.
And in the past, in some cases,
that's what's happened.
That someone has said
we've got patents on,
you know, this sort of
scene-updating technology
or something.
And we sit down,
and we can't make any headway,
and we go out and start
looking around,
and people say,
"Wait a minute.
You got the patent, but like,
ten years before
you ever applied for it,
there were 15 applications
doing it."
And the patent holder looks at
it and says "Yeah, you're right.
Don't worry about it.
Just go ahead and use it."
Schroepfer: So we're
just about out of time.
Or, we are out of time.
Quick closing remarks
from each of you.
We'll start with you, Ian.
Any thoughts you have
for the audience?
Ian: I just--I'm very excited
by the direction
that browsers are going.
I think all the browsers,
both onstage and offstage,
are getting better.
And I know that we're all
very motivated
to continue that direction.
We're all providing a lot
of new functionality.
I hope that you all
in the audience
start taking advantage of it
and certainly give us feedback.
And, you know,
if there's a direction
that you think that we should be
going in that we're not,
let us know.
Jonas: Yeah, I'm very excited
that the web has changed a lot
over the past few years.
Just a few years ago,
nothing was basically happening.
The web had looked the same
for a few years,
and there was no new,
significant innovation.
And now we have, what,
five major browsers
that are very heavily
competing with each other.
And just the improvements
that's happened in JavaScript
are very sort of indicative
of how much competition
and how much improvement
we're actually seeing.
So I'm very excited
to be part of this.
Charles: So it's exciting.
It's like, you know,
we're in this brave new world.
One of the things
that I see more of,
and would like to see a lot
more of, is professionalism.
Let's get together, and let's
do our work on our own
and make it better,
you know.
Because the web started off
being a bunch of cowboys
and a bunch of crazy people
doing stuff
and just lashing it up.
And there is a place for that.
And we should all remember
that if you don't do that,
you stagnate and get bored
and go off and become a mechanic
or a plumber or something.
But there is also a place
for being professional
and caring about quality,
and caring about
maintaining stuff.
Thinking about stuff
that's gonna be around
when you're not working on it
anymore, and where it goes.
And, you know, I see that there
is a whole lot more of that.
And I'd like to see
even more.
The browsers are getting better.
I mean, browsers used to be
this sort of crazy project
that you'd lash together.
Now they're turning into
an important piece of software,
and we're working harder
on making it
a really good piece
of software.
The developers are
getting better.
Developers are actually
thinking harder about
what impact they have,
and what impact it has
when they do a good job.
And what impact it has
when they think about stuff
that's gonna be, maybe, around
for a long time.
Or how they're gonna change it
so that their embarrassing
first effort--
which is always my case--
doesn't stick around.
But it gets replaced
by something cleaner and better.
It's fun.
Schroepfer: Great.
I want to thank the panel
for great thoughts
on browser futures.
Thank you very much.
[applause]